always awesome to talk with you i'm a
big fan of your work um i try to throw i
tried to throw a curve ball or two at
the beginning so
um if someone has never seen anything
that you've ever done what's the first
thing you want them watching and why
i think it's things i think things
pretty much worked out the way they
should be like i think full metal jacket
is the first thing that i did
and i think that's
that would i would prefer that to be the
first thing anybody sees you know
and i think it pretty
much follows in succession after that
you know i think i've had that kind of
career where
um
opportunities have come up in the at the
right time and in the right order
so
yeah i'll stick with full metal jacket
as the first one
uh as i said before i'm a big fan of
your work and i love talking to actors
about like how they actually get ready
for doing like a tough scene so i'm
curious if you're filming something
really tough on a monday maybe it's
really dramatic maybe it's really
emotional how early on are you getting
ready for a scene like that can you
maybe take me through the way you kind
of you know your process if you will
um it's different for each part um
in this particular case with the with
unforgivable it's um
you know it
it was important that
i recognized
um
her trauma
the sanchez characters trauma that she
was going through so i gave my
my character a backstory of being in the
military and
and um becoming a lawyer after that um
you know having his education in the
military as well and and so
um i wanted to be able to be able to
recognize um
pts and in somebody and so i gave him
the military background and i gave him a
uh experience in that himself and so
uh i think that
so the so so when i was thinking about
that one that one particular heavy scene
in in the in the in the movie
um
where she's really
she's really clearly
suffering from something some kind of
trauma
i think that um you know i wanted you
know i i i you know i wanted to be fr
fresh in my mind what how
how you really have to have empathy
towards somebody that's been through an
extreme trauma no matter what you think
of it whether you're
you know whether you believe in what
that person believes in or not you know
it's it's
trauma is real and um
you have to be careful with it you have
to be careful not to judge too harshly
and so that in
other films would be different i would
do different things you know um and uh
but this particular thing was research
and and a few documentaries and stuff
that i could look at to
to make me
go in with something substantial
uh you you have played a lot of tough
guys and i'm just curious if the appeal
of this role specifically was that
you're
um
i don't i don't want to use the term
soft but you have a more sensitive side
and a more caring side if you will to
your character
oh for sure you know i wanted it to be i
didn't want it to be so
i wanted him to look you know to look
like like a real guy like uh you know
i wanted him to be to to look
tough with a uh with you know i wanted
him to look hard but with a soft
interior and so yeah no i would agree i
think it's
um i think it is attractive to me to
play
parts like that occasionally you know um
especially if you're working with really
good actors
it's like it's like playing with it's
like playing any
fun role you know
um
and and if the script is there and
script works
it's all good but yeah i think you're
spot on i think that it was an
attraction to play somebody that had
that was kind of um i had a softer look
on life and
wanted the best for people even though
eventually he gets frustrated by her but
um
and has enough and
but he does he does initially try
and and i like the fact that he looks
the way he looks in the movie and yet
still has a soft material
uh you got to work you you're you're at
a lot of scenes with
scenes with viola and sandra i would
imagine these are very tough days on set
when you have to work with the two of
them i mean they're not professional at
all they're not good actors you really
got to carry the scenes that you're in
those with them i'm sure
yeah it's pretty much the the opposite
of that right
yeah it's uh they are extremely
well prepared actresses and for actors
and
you know uh both of them are very
different and their styles are very
different but
you know for instance
sandra you know she's
she's such a professional she comes in
fully loaded you know like honestly like
she is so
ready when she gets there she's so well
informed both of them are very well
informed um but you know she is clearly
playing the part
um
in a in a you know that's very close to
who you know to a part of herself
you know
and that that's always
fantastic to to work with and then you
know viola is just a visceral
human being she's so you know this lady
is smart and she's
you know she
she knows how to
emote you know
many different colors of emotions and in
one
in one scene and it it it
she's just
you know to to be able to
you know work with with with viola and
watch her juggle all these different
things when the camera's rolling it's
fantastic you know it's it's something
that i've tried to achieve my whole
career and
and you know so
it's just this kind of visceral thing
that goes on and
you know
you just can't have i mean for an act
you know for the reason why i'm in this
business is to have fun like that
like that to me is fun no matter how
heavy the day is or whatever the scene
is about some scenes are fun some are
not so fun
um
in this business but
um they're all kind of fun when it's
going well you got a good script you
have great actors
it's it's the best it can be
uh you directed recently you've directed
a few things um are you thinking about
doing another feature anytime soon
i am yeah yeah there's um i just offered
one the other day i'm not sure if i'm
gonna do it or not but yeah no we're i'm
developing something
um
and uh we're trying to get it off the
ground
so yes
is there anything that you can tease are
you keeping it all close to the vest
no i think i i'll keep it close to the
best until it becomes more real i don't
really don't like talking about things
unless they become
totally real so it's not totally real
yet but it's very close
i know i completely get it my last thing
for you about the film um i really
appreciate that it is depicting
um there's like no easy answers in this
movie it's it's you know dealing with
stuff in a very realistic way can you
sort of talk about that aspect
um yeah i mean it's it you know
one of the things that attracted me to
the movie is that it has substance you
know and that that that
you know there are a lot of fun things
to do these days because of all the
streaming channels and because you know
the venues are just
abundant and within those venues there's
all these different types of movies and
different types of directors in writing
that you can work with and companies you
can work for and it's it's so much fun
it's i love it
um but i still am i still am
mostly attracted to stories that have
substance and
when you can bring a story together that
has substance and is still like a kind
of thriller like this film unforgivable
it's like
you know it's a good combination it's a
you feel like you're
anyway so i feel like i'm going in and
my job is to service that story and
i think it's important you know i i
think it's important to to
have it you know when i get when i have
the chance to
[Music]
to um
create
a character that's going through a human
experience with somebody else
and it could be
it's to somebody else that's driving the
human experience or it could be my carry
that's starting
but i think in this day and age it's
important to every once in a while tell
stories that are about
the human experience
i i completely agree thank you for
giving me your time congrats on the
movie i hope a ton of people watch uh
have a great day
thanks man see ya